venez choses choquantes et albans le
choc initial causés par la prise de
pouvoir des talibans s'estompe peu à peu
les gens sortent dans les rues ils n'ont
plus aussi peur qu'avant les magasins
ouvrent cependant on est toujours dans
le flou les gens ne sont pas certains de
ce qu'il va se passer désormais il
ignore quand les banques vont couvrir
ils ne savent pas ce que les talibans ce
que ces nouveaux talibans vont faire
les talibans d'aujourd'hui prétendent
être très différents des talibans des
années 90 la dernière fois que leurs
combattants ou des cagoules ils se sont
comportés comme des sauvages les
brutalités et les exécutions se sont
multipliés
d'abord nous avons tous eu peur que ce
soit comme en 1996 quand les talibans
sont arrivés au pouvoir mais d'après ce
que nous voyons ils ne sont plus aussi
agressif
les gens avaient peur de se faire tuer
ou kidnappés par les talibans je n'ai
rien vu de ce genre de mes propres yeux
on dit à la télé ou sur youtube que ça
arrive mais je n'ai pas vu de telles
choses moi-même
la baisse est installé largement dans
kaboul les talibans essaient de montrer
qu'ils ont changé l'émirat islamique
selon leur nom officiel connaître un
problème d'image et pas seulement leur
réputation des a précédé des dizaines de
milliers de personnes ont fui kaboul et
le pays elle ne tenait pas à vérifier si
les taliban tiendraient leur promesse d'
amnistie de grâce et de réformes
je n'ai que du mépris pour ceux qui
partent ce sont les cerveaux les jeunes
comment le pays peut-il se remettre et
avancés s'ils s'en vont tous
voilà pourquoi ils font un tel effort de
relations publiques pourquoi ils
laissent les médias étrangers filmé et
discuter avec leurs combattants c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils nous ont laissé
entrer dans leur avant poste afin de
filmer leurs prises de guerre des trois
offices sauvé six mois neuf albans voici
l'un des véhicules hummer des talibans
nous les avons vus sur les vidéos ils en
ont des centaines de ce type ainsi que
des milliers d'autres véhicules
milliards de dollars d'armes de
véhicules de chars et même
d'hélicoptères ont été abandonnées par
l'armée afghanes durant leur retraite
résultat les talibans n'ont pas
suffisamment de drapeaux pour les
installer sur leur propre véhicule à
kaboul dans leur ville ils ont installé
un simple tissu blanc pour symboliser le
drapeau blanc de leur mouvement
la rapide avancée des talibans les a
visiblement épuisé les combattants
dorment peu il y a trop à faire et ils
sont trop peu pour le faire pour
l'instant mais cela n'a pas entamé leur
zèle
nous avons lutté pendant des années pour
l'indépendance de l'afghanistan face aux
américains et nous continuerons à la sab
le mans à combattre les envahisseurs de
plus en plus de gens nous rejoignent
avec le temps notre frère a perdu sa
jambe dans le combat mais nous sommes
avec lui et il est avec nous nous ne
sommes pas fatigués nous ne nous
fatiguerons jamais
les talibans ont étudié les usages du
monde la manière forte le zèle et le
fanatisme c'est bien pour les
combattants mais les leaders ont besoin
de garder les idées claires voilà
pourquoi ils font preuve de plus de
réserves alors que les têtes brûlées
sont tenus en laisse par des combattants
plus vieux et plus expérimentés
pour moi chez les citoyens afghans qui
ont travaillé et coopérer avec les
forces américaines et européennes qui
ont traduit pour eux mais aussi pour
leurs ambassades sur leur organisation
qui travaille est ici il existe chez
tous ces gens la condition absolue que
cela va se produire que vous allez tuer
tous ceux qui étaient contre les
talibans maintenant que vous êtes au
pouvoir est ce le cas
bien sûr que nous ne les avons pas mais
s'ils veulent partir ils peuvent partir
ils peuvent aller en amérique mais ils
ne seront pas loyaux pour autant ce sont
des traîtres mais l'émirat y va tous là
a ordonné de ne pas les toucher ils font
l'objet d'une amnistie et nous ne les
toucheront donc pas ceux qui disent que
nous l'étions menthe
les talibans n'ont pas réellement été
fidèles à leur parole il ya eu un
certain nombre d'exécutions de meurtre
de ce qu'ils aidaient les forces
étrangères ou s'opposait aux talibans
après plusieurs jours ici à kaboul il
devient évident que talibans font face à
un énorme manque d'effectifs alors
combattants travail trop et sont sous
pression pourtant de toute évidence ces
nouveaux talibans sont là pour gagner je
reprends l'expression les coeurs et les
esprits des afghans plutôt que de les
briser comme leur effet les talibans de
jadis reste encore à voir s'ils sont
vraiment